les parties de bureau sont établies
comme une tradition presque
incontournable et une récompense pour
les employés à la fin de l'année avec un
mois de décembre qui s'annonce difficile
selon la santé publique est-il judicieux
d'assister à ces réjouissante contenu du
risque d'apporter le virus à la maison
si on peut le faire en plus petit comité
c'est l'idéal et si on peut le faire à
l'extérieur c'est encore mieux alors
peut-être être imaginatif mais faut être
vraiment prudent si on veut passer des
fêtes en famille puis avec nos proches
sans avoir été contaminés par quelque
chose et sans le propager
de bureau on a vraiment ça nous a manqué
pendant les deux dernières années je
comprends mais à ce moment-là si vous
pouvez peut-être le faire dans une plus
grande salle donc oui maintenir les
rassemblements entre collègues à
condition de porter le masque à
l'intérieur de ventiler le plus possible
la salle où l'on se trouve et de se
limiter un seul parti de bureau sinon de
le faire en plus petit nombre
et après deux ans de pandémie bien
décollé que je semble avoir envie de se
retrouver virus ou pas on est dû
ça fait du bien de se revoir et si les
gens sur le responsabilisent puis on n'a
pas de symptômes quand on y va c'est
correct non notre vie a repris comme la
normale j'y vais j'ai mon partenaire
mardi prochain
écoutez moi j'y vais avec plaisir
car nous les restaurateurs confirment la
tendance avec des carnets de réservation
plein on est enfin revenu au modèle de
2019 donc on voit qu'on va avoir une
bonne saison des fêtes comme on l'avait
prépare des MI et c'est un super de
soulagement pour l'industrie après les
deux dernières années où on ne peut plus
faire de vente au mois de décembre bref
la vigilance reste de mise prévienne les
experts même si le cœur est plus que
jamais à la fête ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal